hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to a
special vagina edition of the ridiculous
where we're exploring all the BS that
you can buy for your bush so first up on
the ridiculous is the vagina stick i
want to take it right on your vagina
stick vagina chick like a lot of this
ladies when are we gonna stop putting
stuff in our vagina tampon by fingers
great penis amazing dildo yeah my
enthusiasm intense right now what I'm
trying to say though is unless it's
helping you get off you don't even spend
$40 on this stick now let's take a look
at what the website has to say according
to this website
the Japanese vagina stick has been used
for centuries by women in Asia Arabia
and Persia and can apparently tighten
and cleanse the vagina of course it can
now apparently it regenerates the
vaginas skin tissue by removing dead
cells restores the vaginal flora and
balances pH there's a lot of shady
business happening on this website first
of all there's a lot of medical-grade
stick-like devices that you can buy out
there that are recommended by pelvic
floor therapists they can help with
kegels and to help you strengthen your
pelvic floor but that is the only
benefit I can see out of a stick like
this and surprisingly he gel's are not
even included in their how-to guide all
it says is that you just leave it up
there for a hot minute and let it work
it's mama juju magic like hocus pocus
cleanse me baby
bibbidi-bobbidi bibbidi-bobbidi-boo
also for a special treat you should
totally google vagina magic spells and
yeah you won't be disappointed step 4
you will win like nothing
it happens as for the bogus cocktail of
herbs like aloe vera saffron and pearl
powder currently there's no research
into the safety of these things in your
vajayjay but most experts do worm that
you should never put anything up inside
your peach unless it's being recommended
by your OB a lot of these herbs and
natural food ingredients can irritate
your little gaga
but also they can definitely impact your
beneficial bacteria out there so hard no
for me no no no no also can we talk
about the messed up slogan here flatout
on the homepage feel tight and wanted
again what the actual [ __ ] not to come
on like a feminist rant here but if you
push a watermelon out of your Twinkie
you better become the most wanted human
being that your partner has ever met
listen ladies if you're dealing with a
sleeve of wizard post childbirth like
some of us are oh hey yeah taking up
with your pelvic floor therapist not
some sketchy website next number two on
the ridiculous is the camel toe cushion
this product is embarrassingly popular
so this is described on our website as
an eco-friendly reusable solution to the
fashion faux-pas this garment helps
prevent your clothes from riding up your
couch it didn't say that on the website
but that's what it does but as the
comments on the website have led me to
believe this is basically just a
glorified panty liner with a few pieces
of tape for 20 bucks I get that the
camel toe is kind of uncomfortable and
not very flattering in most situations
however I never realized there was such
a high demand to deal with a yo-yo
smuggler until I searched camel toe on
Amazon so many options not surprisingly
most of them are really poorly reviewed
which I think just goes to prove that
when the beaver is hungry you just got
to eat so I guess as one commenter
suggested ladies don't hide your gift
maybe save your $20 and just invest in
some larger pants that won't consume
your crotch next
alright number three on the ridiculous
is vaginal sunbathing surprisingly this
wasn't one of Gweneth recommendations
but I guess shailene woodley just beat
her to it with his croc recommendation
this super-fun hell trend is exactly
what it sounds like
letting your lady bits hang out in the
Sun to get a little color
now the actress who popularized this
trend was quoted as saying I like to
give my vagina a little vitamin D I was
reading an article written by an
herbalist about yeast infections and
other genital issues obviously and she
said there was nothing better than
vitamin D if you live in a place that
has heavy winters when the Sun finally
does come out spread your legs and get
some sunshine I'm sorry but are you sure
that this herbalist is not some like
creepy ass man just trying to get into
your pants or is this the laziest excuse
to get you two to lay around
spread-eagle with your junk exposed to
the elements cuz I'm all for going
commando
but maybe take it indoors so based on my
research I found just one study
suggesting that taking 2,000 IU's of
vitamin D may be an effective treatment
for bacterial vaginosis not great
evidence that there's a direct link but
sure added to the reasons that we love
the sunshine vitamin what I did not find
in the evidence is a recommendation that
you should just lay around with your
pom-pom pocono to get your fix taking a
supplement is definitely the safest way
to protect your delicate skin but even
just 10 minutes on exposed arms or legs
is usually enough folks I am no prude
but if it's vitamin D you're after I say
put your pants on and just take a pill
next
next on the Ridiculist is vagina mints
I mean hey have stinky breath pop a mint
have a stinky snatch insert a mint I can
just imagine the room full of nail
marketing execs just coming up with the
raunchy key messaging for this well
here's what they came up with for the $8
tin of mints this product is designed to
extend the time your partner will want
to spend tasting the new you great
ladies finally a sex product that
benefits us longer cunnilingus session
Louie I know these myths may cost you $8
a box but tack on another $20 box of
Coniston to get your box back into shape
or it should be because something is
definitely gonna be growing up in there
long story short the primary ingredient
in these mints is not surprisingly sugar
which with our tacos microflora and of
course can lead to bacterial infection
it's pretty well accepted that we should
not be storing sugar in our girl garage
but a lot of these companies can get
away with it by simply using the words
for novelty use only so that way if
anyone would like come after them they
can simply come back and say hey we
didn't expect you dumb women would
actually put this in your muff we just
thought it was for fun Z so ladies
please
do not put candy in your badge and
everybody else partners out there learn
to worship your partner's natural aroma
and taste okay next
and finally passion dust
let's close this off with a bang because
if a minty fresh kitty wasn't enough for
you let's make your next orgasm look
like a king unicorn Queen I haven't said
the word queef since like high school I
didn't ever expect that I would have a
job where I had to talk about queefing
but here I am you proud mom all right
back to the glitter so this gelatin
tablet dissolves in your vagina
releasing a ton of glitter that
according to the website makes you
magically delicious
Oh bomb thankfully this product has
since been pulled from the web but it
did not stop it from selling a ton
hundreds of units in just a few days as
for the safety the website does feature
a small disclaimer that explains
unscientifically that it could
potentially lead to an asthma attack if
inhaled during oral sex
totally but that is definitely not all a
lot of experts also learned that the
sugar in the capsule could cause
bacterial overgrowth increase the risk
of sti's change the vaginas pH and cause
contact dermatitis in your sweet little
cookie now I love a little shimmer and
sparkle in my beauty regime but that is
getting a hard pass from me so here is
what we learned
don't put [ __ ] up your minge without
doctor supervision not sparkles not
candies not
sticks nothing your vagina is an example
of a physiological self-sustaining
mother amazing for again it doesn't need
to be cleansed it doesn't need to be
manipulated and unlike your hair or your
nails or your lashes most people aren't
seeing it anyway and the people who are
should appreciate it as it is so I say
it is absolutely not worth messing with
so guys I hope you enjoyed this video if
you did be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below some crazy
wellness trends or products that you've
seen that you've loved me to review
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]